all right let's talk a little bit about
um uh
personal finance i guess in a sense
let's talk about the national savings
rate uh as a result of the pandemic and
sort of some other
related topics and we'll sort of build
up to uh what some are calling kind of
like new asset allocations that make
sense for the average person
nothing in this video is is financial
advice just as a reminder we're just
talking about
some of these issues there's a very
interesting article in the atlantic by
robert shapiro called what the u.s
loses when americans save too much and
it points out
accurately that during the pandemic
americans sucked more away than at any
time
in recent memory and that that's a
problem
um what the uh article argues
is that quote as the pandemic recedes
the economy faces a serious new
challenge
the personal savings rate remains high
14.9
in april 12.4 percent in may with large
unemployment benefits and waves of free
cash now starting to recede
in the country's rearview mirror the
continuation of that high level of
personal savings threatened a strong
expansion into 2022 and 2023.
this is basically a demand side economic
perspective
the article goes on to say because a
dollar saved is a dollar
unspent any sudden enormous jump in
personal savings would normally
devastate consumer spending and economic
growth
fortunately both the trump and biden
administrations
managed to get the economics of the
pandemic right the united states averted
a sustained economic catastrophe
by pumping up people's incomes with
emergency payouts
while savings rates were soaring
the article goes on to say the final
result is that even with gdp and job
numbers cratering in the second quarter
of 2020
and the highest savings rate in 75 years
the growth in personal incomes from all
sources including checks from the
government
accelerated a lot during the pandemic
total personal income increased by 1.4
trillion that's 7.6 percent
those income gains outpaced the 4.4
average annual income growth from 2015
to 2019. so
the idea here is and this is a that you
know when we talk about
why is it that tax cuts for the really
rich aren't that good for the economy
it's for the same reason that robert
shapiro is arguing that people saving a
lot of money
isn't that great for the economy uh
which is that
if you have a low marginal propensity to
consume to spend
meaning you're really rich you don't
need any additional money to fund your
lifestyle and somebody gives you a
little more money
the odds that you spend that and insert
it into the economy so it will circulate
and multiply through an economic
multiplier is very low you'll sock it
away in a bank account more likely
that's the same demand side concern if
americans overall are
saving much more are participating
in an activity not spending that is not
particularly economically stimulative
and that is a that that is a really big
deal at a macroeconomic level the other
thing that's sort of going on
as all of this is happening and i don't
pretend to know what the impact of it is
going to be
is that more and more legacy financial
firms
and you can like them or not you can
trust them or not but a lot of people
pay attention to them
are starting to say that the average
person could or even
in some cases should make cryptocurrency
a part of their portfolio
jpmorgan for example says they they said
it months ago
investors could make bitcoin one percent
of portfolios
there are other firms that talk about
three to four percent
i've said before not financial advice
that
from my instinct my belief after owning
bitcoin for
i don't know uh five six years at this
point
i think it's clearly not going away and
so i'm like a
four to five percent of my total assets
type of guy
as that is happening you could see the
combination
of a high savings rate as well as saving
some of that money in cryptocurrency
which could lead to a dramatically
different
sort of economy three to five years from
now i don't pretend to know exactly the
way in which it will be different but
there's no question that that certainly
would
uh and that sort of relates actually to
a platform
that uh i've been trying out lately that
i'll take a second just to tell you
about uh this
the platform is called bit levex this
video was
sponsored by bit levex after we reached
out to them we partnered up on this
video
they have a really unique product it's
basically options with leverage
i've never really traded options before
i've been wanting to just
dip my toe in a little bit find out how
they're priced and so on
and i was surprised to find out that
there's a really fascinating model
behind it called the black and shoals
model which won a nobel prize
in economics so i tried the bit levex
platform i was impressed with how easy
it was
i did a little bit of trading you can
have a look at some of my results the
profit percentages that you see there
so this could be a useful tool if you're
involved in trading and you want to work
quickly
there's leverage available up to 100 the
options can be sold back after five
minutes
so i can control risk from several
angles including
leverage and time to maturity one thing
i really liked about
levex is the personal attention to every
user you have a personal manager you can
talk to on the phone
if you want they'll talk to you about
how to trade options how to manage risk
it's all free had a really interesting
and informative conversation
they have options on you know all the
popular assets tesla stock amazon stock
netflix bitcoin others so you can do
both traditional and crypto assets on
one platform
the withdrawals are fast you can do
paypal which makes it convenient
deposits are commission free which is
not that common
user-friendly platform lots of hands-on
support
and i put a link to bitlovex under the
video if you want to check it out and
again as always do your due diligence
never invest what you're unwilling to
lose i'm not giving financial advice
uh i am just telling you about my
experience with the bit levex
platform which it and platforms like it
are increasingly being adopted by people
who are saying
let me do what jpmorgan is saying or let
me do what whoever is saying
let me try putting one percent two
percent sometimes three percent whatever
makes sense for your sort of risk
profile and appetite
into alternative currencies digital
currencies cryptocurrencies
i don't know anything about anything my
my approach is basically time
in the market beats timing the market
and that's why
with my stocks and bonds i'm a buy and
hold guy
with my cryptocurrencies i've been
mostly a buy and hold guy just selling
individual tranches to lock in some
gains
and i think we're increasingly going to
see that particularly again because of
the combination of the high savings rate
as well as the accessibility of a lot of
these new platforms